we are here
we are here where do we go that way
how are you are we eventually going that
way is it just right through there
morning yeah 25
left one child behind this is it this is
it
Wow pretty cool huh nah man this is
literally the first time I've been here
no way this is the first time I've been
here this is it I've never been here
before
hey sky give me a kiss oh yes it's the
big day so excited it's so crazy huh Wow
Jesus this is so cool
what's this so cool the office is so
intense look at this
Statue of Liberty these people have six
seats right Caldwell Davis Glennon
hooker right
what's all that I want to say it holy
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] this is amazing this
is so legit I can't even believe this is
our office is this insane yeah is this
how we do all hands you're looking right
at the Statue of Liberty is it we did it
all right my room is legit guys I don't
want to look at it I'm so excited
the garden baby yes it's so cozy this is
so cool you guys set it up proper I love
it this we're gonna do show hey
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk is
that my office all my stuff so the new
backdrop for the askgaryvee show
everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk Misha
Xander this is daddy's new office look
at this all my stuff
there's d-roc what do you think horse I
love that there's all these conference
rooms by my office I swing here and I
can see a lot of people it's me a lot
easier to get you guys
I guess I'll just sit here right ya know
hi guys are you mourning mourning how I
was this like this is amazing I've no
idea
wait after just probably some sort of
all morning brother it's gone
hey morning morning
crazy right good stuff look at the
garden right there right there good
morning it's crazy this is where some
I've been here at least on spire here
you think I'm inspired regardless I
could be inspired Alexis I always
inspired if they put me like in a jail
salad how do you been yet no this is so
awesome
Wow it is wild that's like a good way to
put it
we go sick this is they sang a little
different than a budding beauty
accomplishment man this is so awesome
the Iraq wait - this way - it's 11
o'clock here and it's buzzing you want
to sit my office yeah Gary
hi I'm all ready nice party Harry Romy
Romy how are you good
do you know if you're on 25 or 24 on
this got it yeah there's yeah okay good
good luck this is super fun
whoever Pell a signed jersey I don't
even know that this is great I feel like
we're gonna do damage I feel like I
could see your face now so much more I
feel like that's at least eight to nine
more viral hits I think there's a lot in
the Elvis Durant today's a very special
day today vaynermedia moves into its new
office and I'm very excited about it and
decays got a seat detox got his normal
spot regardless of office look how sick
this is look at this conference room
Hudson Yards big new project
there's Jersey I love it Madison Square
Garden that close loved it Oh Michael
Romo got a big time see seriously on a
clear day that's gonna be unbelievable
there's the Statue of Liberty
boom how sick is that to see the Statue
of Liberty on a nice day at 9:00 a.m.
right here on Facebook launching a video
that I think pretty much everybody in
the world needs to see it's called
August drops today it's very very
important for all of you
so we're getting to another great part
what's this little area uh-huh you love
this are you 100% stand up yeah this is
you yeah women you have this whole desk
is you know it's too okay I was gonna
say that's a lot too much what do you
have to say in the vaynernation so happy
to be here this is Mel a long time to
come and it's amazing and what about
this picture oh these are the golden
girls my favorite the entire row love it
love you more honestly the company
started in a conference room like that
like that size this conference room me
sang Marcus and AJ and definitely not
this kind of you like you know what's
great about this conference room is
first of all like the views are so
ridiculous but like this conference
rooms perfect for like my morning like
leadership meetings because if you're
late for it and you come through there
we could all like sit like it's like a
whole we yeah it's a whole weird thing
pretty cool big day
pretty excited about it hey mate this is
nuts
have you been here me neither I'm free
get out
did you see the calf the calf cafeteria
oh yeah the kitchen is that where you
got that
no no snapchat go to Facebook right now
check my new August video share that
[ __ ] up it's important it's gonna be a
good way Gilles is it unbelievable
unbelievable did you see my office
yeah I'm sitting in alright got it did
you see the cafeteria I walked through
it I had no idea I have no idea - I've
never been here
get out I've never been here
that's how I roll I came in today like
it's a new building probably pretty nice
you know lalala game up I mean it's the
views and they're like the Statue of
Liberty happy birthday bro
welcome thank you
unbelievable huh yes finally so first
time I've heard that how did you guys
win the lotto look this is insane holy
[ __ ] yeah you'd be okay with this Leo
get this all to begin with this morning
I'm Gary such a pleasure
yeah is this like an official meeting
here like you guys booked it like today
you just booked you just press what do
you do this conference room is so
ridiculous ty where's my meeting in
Godzilla it's amazing so good on the
smile
the Statue of Liberty that's my favorite
part really well
some gang hey morning fell brother oh I
love the one fit one view you get in the
statute look like the one peep you get
is the Statue of Liberty
you should literally sometimes just like
and people like yeah just be like
there's some people give me like always
he's creating he's super creating he's
creating he's super created when he gets
pissed he could just be like all right
let me just sent it out a little I'm
aware look at that that shot
it's really like flies to the light
pretty cool huh steam just like our old
office Steve were you in the process at
this there's a long way from due process
you have to leave eventually you can't
you can't see it you can't sit here
forever
sorry my work do you know how home I
feel I literally in my office look at
Madison Square Garden it's unreal
dude I gotta admit though of course of
your [ __ ] sketch I don't know why the
Statue of Liberty like that is [ __ ]
awesome
Brandon not to a one righteous side yeah
here yep get them Daniel what's your
favorite flavor so far yeah yeah you
guys have to fix this because I just
want you guys to know I'm dominant in
this gated like DOM and like I'm all
time I'm Russian there's a puck so cool
I love the action of the kitchen I feel
like my office is gonna be the kitchen
yeah this cereal is freaking people out
no here's my thing there's my thing I
have a real concern about anybody that
starts now I feel like they're gonna be
I feel like they're gonna be like yeah
they're like yes I feel like we got to
go back to something before 373
I feel like I feel like all of you are
gonna do what I do to my children right
but like when we were in 350 you know
I'm telling you right now get ready for
I'm telling her now get ready for a
month from now you saying to somebody
who's going to complain about something
like what I said a broom closet okay be
like I'm sure - yes okay what happened
we know my free time everybody knows
everything life no I meant any watered
worried I stuff that's a good job maybe
he je vais I was like I was trying to
get catch you I was like you don't water
these things like no you ice them I'm
like yeah you're on your game and he's
got a green thumb they look better did
you just get today
you
from the ground up I built it what are
you tend to bring in town oh I'll tell
you look how cool is this look how look
how ridiculous is like we're like by far
the small think we need a picture we're
going so late I've gotta be on stage
alarm
back away - girls like that Gaea because
we just win every day we went every day
when every day we played every day
here you be someone I'm there in a gave
me money are you doing sir no pleasure
man too bad you got a rough shot we got
a really good party after was some dog
and French Montana I gotta get I gotta
get to LA
nicely Chanel
thank you brother gotta do want make it
out to me
because the end consumer is the only
thing that matters I really didn't want
Twitter to lose its lead that it had six
years ago as a lot of you know that's
where I really blew up from I'm not
pumped that with 1.3 million followers
that I can't get anywhere close to the
conversion that I did five years ago or
six years ago with a hundred fifty
thousand or two hundred thousand
followers it's just a tension arbitrage
that's awesome thanks Derek you got
Alexi why are you taking all the credit
for her work I'm just the executive
that's nice too much fun
I'm so sorry I'm sorry I'm so sorry
real pleasure response anemometer
yeah yeah go boo brewski not o not only
from the same place yes the first time
thank you brother Ursula take it out
come and stay well thank you well
thanks Gary
love never charged Blaugrana
got it away is if flowers on a block we
in the blog right now yeah uh yeah how
are you thank you guys
hey well thank you
theories
forty-seven is this it
just give me my guy yep it's me yeah so
crazy
yeah can't we
Jason your water thing thank you my man
Gary Gary
everybody's right
this is sound anyway no weapon the night
like nicely do you know what geniuses
to say no say no she did she oh no tell
pop singer park that UFO
I said that go oh well I catch fire
now in from above Neverland back away
duck off just like that sky epic we just
went every day
and everyday
every day every day
you